l'autre jour j'étais en train de
cuisiner est un peu gourmand j'ai fait
trop de nourriture c'était du gâchis
alors je me suis demandé est ce qui
serait pas possible d'inventer une
machine pour tes cuire les aliments un
petit coup dans le des cuiseurs et hop
de belle patate redevenu tout dure
malheureusement ça semble physiquement
impossible sauf pour un aliment des
scientifiques ont en effet réussi à des
cuirs à neuf et on vous explique comment
y'a quoi dans un 9 rebonds on sait tous
qu'il ya du blanc et du jaune ce qu'on
sait moins c'est que ce sont deux
matières chimiquement très différentes
leblanc scientifiquement ça s'appelle
l'albumen et c'est quasiment que de
l'eau avec 10 % de protéines diverses au
contraire du jaune qu'on appelle vie
telus et qui n'est que du gras 98 5%
sous diverses formes la couleur jaune ll
est provoqué par deux pigments naturels
ne vous êtes-vous jamais demandé
pourquoi un tout petit peu de ce jaune
d'oeuf trouvait complètement faire
foirer vos oeufs battus en neige eh bien
c'est exactement cause de ça normalement
quand vous faites votre gâteau vous
séparer le blanc du jaune et vous battez
les blancs à ce moment là des pulls des
airs se font piéger dans les protéines
ce qui fait de la mousse ça c'est parce
que l'ovalbumine du blanc est un
tensioactifs une molécule avec un côté
hydrophile qui aiment l'eau et l'autre
pas du tout c'est là où l'herbe à se
mettre sauf quand vous mettez du jaune
le côté hydrophobe est tout de suite
attiré par le gras et arrête de piéger
l'air c'est grâce à ce côté tensioactifs
qui le rend aussi indispensable pour des
tas de plats ont sonné aussi servi pour
faire de la colle dans le vin pour
soigner des blessures pour décorer un
livre et même pour développer des photos
plus inattendu on peut se servir du
blanc pour cultiver des bacs sein la
grippe par exemple on injecte le virus
dans le blanc d'oeuf pour qu'ils
puissent se développer puis on les
récupère on laurent inoffensif et on en
fait des doses eh oui l'oeuf est bien
plus complexe que juste du jaune et du
blanc imaginez maintenant ce qu'il se
passe quand on applique de la chaleur
qu'est ce qui se passe quand on q19 cuir
ça n'est pas que réchauffer c'est aussi
irrémédiablement modifier la chimie d'un
objet par exemple un steak dans une
poêle sa part est innocent mais sous vos
yeux se déroulent des milliards de
réactions chimiques
violente et irrémédiable le gras de la
viande va s'oxyder en composés s'étonner
et aldéhydes et les sucres vont se
polymérisé en immense chêne de centaines
d'atomes et du côté des protéines elles
vont réagir avec les sucres dans ce
qu'on appelle la réaction de maillard ça
va provoquer des dizaines de réactions
chimiques à la chaîne revenir la viande
et former ses bonnes odeurs de cuisson
ouais dans ta cuisine tu es un chimiste
sans le savoir mais pour ce qui est des
oeufs eh bien ça cuit sion a une grosse
différence par rapport à la viande d'un
milieu fermé rien entre rien ne sort
donc pas de molécule extérieur pour
venir compliquer la réaction mais si on
ne peux rien ajouter ou retirer et que
sont blancs c'est juste 90% d'eau c'est
pas logique que ça ressorte solide ah
oui l'eau s'évapore pas vu que c'est
fermé du coup il se passe quoi
l'intérieur pour que lou se transforme
en ça pour comprendre ça on va devoir
faire un zoom au niveau moléculaire vous
ouvrez des 10 % de protéines dans le
blanc dont on parle et elle ressemble à
ça de longues chaînes repliée sur
elle-même imagine ces protéines comme
des écouteurs en mêlée dans tes poches
qui forment des petites boules
indépendante c'est pour ça que le blanc
2 illiquides les protéines ne sont pas
attachées ensemble chaque plume glisse
les unes sur les autres tout ça ça va
changer avec la chaleur les petits liens
qui retenaient les protéines en boule
vont se casser elles vont alors se
délier en longues chaînes de molécules
comme si des milliers vous écouteurs et
vous comprenez maintenant le problème la
chaleur va les agiter les mélanger c'est
comme si vous aviez un bol géant
d'écouteurs des mulets et que vous le
soukous est à fond un blanc d'oeuf c'est
comme manger votre pire cauchemar c'est
pour ça d'ailleurs que le transparent
devient blanc les protéines sont
tellement resserré les unes avec les
autres que la lumière ne passent même
plus au travers mais du coup ci c'est la
chaleur qui provoque tout ça il devrait
suffire de refroidir l'oeuvre pour que
tout redevienne comme avant et bien non
parce que baisser la température va
juste diminuer les vibrations donc
l'oeuf va juste rester figé dans l'état
dans lequel on l'a mis dans ce cas
faisons inverse et si on le chauffe et
encore plus pour augmenter les
vibrations à force les molécules de
brice délit et non ça serait un peu
comme chauffée du chocolat non plus ça
ne le ferai que cuir encore plus voir le
ferez brûlé rien ne semble marcher sauf
avec la science la technique secrète
pour des cuire un oeuf et si je vous
disais qu'on pouvait des cures à neuf en
le secouant bon et c'est pas chez toi
ans un peu plus compliqué déjà il nous
faut un ingrédient spécial de l'urée ce
motu dit peut-être quelque chose et
c'est normal vu que c'est ce qu'on
retrouve dans son urine mais pas que la
transpiration et le sang aussi c'est pas
sale en fait ces terrains qui transforme
l'ammoniac une molécule potentiellement
mortelle pour toi en ceinture et
inoffensive mais c'est quoi le rapport
avec les oeufs en fait le raid un
lubrifiant alors inutile du régner sur
ta porte pour qu'elle arrête de queen et
on parle de lubrifiants moléculaire et
s'assure le blanc d'oeuf dur ça va avoir
l'effet de décoller les protéines elles
restent en mêlée mais maintenant elle
flotte et ne collent plus entre elles on
peut donc passer aux choses sérieuses
vous mettez dans un bol vaublanc de
couper en petits morceaux dans une
solution daury dur et puis vous remuer
pendant ces heures c'est long au bout
desquels vous aurez à liquide
translucide et légèrement trouble
leblanc 2 est redevenu liquide mais
malheureusement les protéines sont
toujours d'ailier il faut pouvoir les
enrouler dans leur position d'origine
c'est à ce moment là que vous aurez
besoin de lavaur text bouddhique device
une machine super cher qui se trouvent
dans quelques labo seulement et qui
permet de faire tourner des trucs nous
on va faire tourner notre liquide avec
une inclinaison de 45 degrés et une
vitesse de 5000 tours minute pendant
cinq minutes ce qui va se passer c'est
que dans le tube il y aura différentes
vitesses de rotation selon où on se
trouve ça va créer des forces qui vont
faire étirer les protéines dans tous les
sens et les faire se replier vu que
c'est un tube le liquide au centre ira
moins vite que celui sur l'extérieur du
coup à cause des différences de vitesse
des protéines vont se cogner les unes
contre les autres jusqu'à retrouver leur
forme d'origine
après ça suffit de retirer lui répare
décantation car le blanc de est plus
lourd et hop le tour est joué vous avez
votre blanc deux revenus comme avant et
vous pouvez même leur cuir ccid et cuire
un oeuf est utile à la science ben ouais
tu peux pas de servir de cette méthode
de des cuissons à la maison une machine
à plusieurs dizaines de milliers de
dollars de l'urée et une journée pour
1,9 c'est pas très rentable alors
pourquoi on félicite des chercheurs en
leur donnant un prix car oui ils ont
reçu un prix de chine c'est con hein
niño belle c'est une sorte de prix nobel
pour récompenser des recherches
sérieuses sur des sujets loufoque par
exemple la façon dont on casse les
spaghettis en gros un spaghetti c'est
super long et rigide donc si on le pli
ça casse l'expérience ici c'était de
prendre les spaghettis en les tenant par
les boues et d'essayer de le casser en
deux morceaux seulement il faut les
tenir par les extrémités un sinon c'est
trop facile malheureusement quand plie
le spaghetti il explose toujours en au
moins trois morceaux plus jamais
seulement en deux alors ils ont essayé
d'expliquer ça et en gros c'est parce qu
nom de sueur courbure va venir tout
faire casser parfois plusieurs fois
avant que l'on normale et le temps de
faire un aller-retour ceci dit il existe
bien une façon de casser un spaghetti en
deux comme ça faut le faire tourner un
peu pour que l'on ne puisse pas se
propager correctement quand ils cassent
une telle démonstration sert à
comprendre des choses bien plus concrète
comme pourquoi et comment les ponts se
brise vous voyez c'est pas inutile du
coup commandes et cuire un oeuf fait
avancer la science bah c'est pas leur
intérêt mais plutôt la technique
utilisée pour replier les protéines car
par exemple pour les médicaments il faut
que les molécules soit pliée d'une
certaine façon pour que ça marche une
molécule identique mais plier
différemment n'aura pas du tout les
mêmes effets avec notre méthode on peut
remédier à ça ça va même plus loin cette
technique nous permettrait carrément de
créer des graphène un matériau
incroyable extrêmement conducteur le
souci c'est que c'est des feuilles très
difficile à décoller les unes des autres
on en avait déjà parlé dans la vidéo sur
les téléphones du futur et bien grâce au
vortex physique des vikes la machine qui
tourne vite on est capable faire des
feuilles de carbone qui ne font qu'un
atome d'épaisseur qui l'eût cru que des
histoires duff nous amène aussi loin
j'espère que la vidéo vous a plu on
remercie les rédacteurs avec alexandre
et wesli les monteurs pensez à vous
abonner on a vraiment besoin de votre
force allez les amis ciao
[Musique]